are women happier today
are you i am
i'm very independent i'm very happy i
get always more i i ask for more i
always get more
so
does independence lead to happiness yes
oh yes when i'm with the men actually
it just stops me so so like so if you
were 60 it's childless and by yourself
if you were 65 let's say childless by
yourself no family you'd be like you
think you'd be happy yeah with a dog
ooh
she said a dog kevin samuel says buy a
dog and die alone i would have two dogs
so the dog has someone to play with when
i'm not at home so i'm not that selfish
you know but yeah i'll be very happy a
nice house in front of the beach two
dogs there i would have men by like
dessert you know how do you know
28.
see if you're if you think that at 38.
so maybe i'm dead let's see
no i don't wish death on yourself no i'm
not me neither but you never know yeah
but i'm saying like because now i think
like
women that are in their younger years
think yeah i'm
because i'm happy now right and i
and i'm single now and i'm independent
now
i'm going to be i'm going to have this
mindset into my 50s and 60s but when you
get to like your 40s 50s and 60s you
tend to want some kind of companionship
you tend to want somebody who you'd like
to like be with on a day to day or on a
week-to-week basis someone to hold
someone to go to sleep with but you know
it at that point in time a lot of women
tend to
think that they're going to have the
same mindset like i'm 41
right but
yeah i know i look good right yeah black
don't crash
melanin who's the secret
but i'm just saying like um a lot of
people think that they have the same i
never had the same mindset that i have
now than when i did when i was 25. you
know i mean 28. you know i mean and at
that age i thought i knew it all i
thought yeah i know exactly what i want
yeah i'm going to be like this rest of
my life i'm telling you
time changes your mind and you may think
that now but as you get to 38 and you
have to be like yeah i'm going to buy a
dog i'm going to be like by myself by
the beach i'm telling you you're going
to want a companion over 42 that are
single childless and make between fifty
and a hundred thousand are the least
happy and the most medicated
there you go
um
i saw some messages like from elderly
care you know hillary care calorie
people and most of women they say don't
date
you know and they're old
that's that's an example of women they
smile in their face but i've been in a
relationship before for seven years and
i was very happy and i just broke up
because i moved from switzerland to
london
you know i know but it is a relationship
i know what it is to be with someone you
don't want that again
oh yes but not now
i just feel
um i had a man it's hot girl summer
season now
and not because
it's hot girl summer season
but it's not because of that it's
because
i feel
a man right now would
uh
delay me in a way because what i want in
life
it i just need to be focused i just need
to think about me just me i cannot share
so much time with a person if that makes
sense i hate you yeah so i don't want to
be selfish i don't want to be narcissist
in a way like he's giving me so much and
then i just cannot give the same so i'm
just very aware of that so i just feel
like probably i would have like
how you say how you call a hook up
there
and there here and there yeah and there
and that works for you in the machine no
i don't think so that's the thing i
don't think so it doesn't work i want to
try because i never i never tried that's
the thing i'm curious no oh because i've
been always a kind of girl like so you
relationship you essentially want to be
for the streets
kind of because i don't know the streets
so you want to see what these streets
are about the streets
they put even a caption in the photo
like me is going to flow the streets you
know
like feminism teaches to women that
sleeping around is going to make you
happy
and it's not you know your your chance
of a happy marriage if you if you're a
virgin when you get married your your
chance of being happily married is
eighty percent right yeah and it drops
down to thirty percent if you've slept
with more than five people
well what come again
it drops down
if you've slept with more than five
people
and it just keeps getting lower and
lower
the more guys you sleep with it gets
lower and lower because you know why you
know better what you know what you want
in bed you know sex is it it is
important
right and it's not just sex people think
it's just sex or [ __ ] it's not it's
about intimacy you know and it's about
what you like and what are you for
for
which person for the male or
uh female because i'm just a female
because as a guy i would tell you a guy
can have sex with a hole in the wall and
be cool
what i'm telling you a guy
a guy can have sex with a woman i i was
exaggerating there but a guy can have
sex with a woman and not need the
intimacy
that's not true
i'm a man i'm telling you a guy can have
sex with a woman and not need the
intimacy ah you don't need it of course
not but i'm just saying it is important
and once you have it believe me it's
much better than sex i don't disagree
with you but i'm saying guys can go
through their life having and that's a
reason why um only fans and porn it in
my opinion why only fans and porn is so
popular because guys can just jerk off
and be cool yeah but women that does
like we watch part two yeah but the
industry is it's a male-led industry
it's like the the most consumers of like
porn and only fans are male 1 they're
not females most women are sexually
active we're men that's not the case one
or three men under 30 are either virgins
or haven't had sex in a year
and that is why only fans and porn is so
um popular because these men these
averages these men are just in their
houses just jacking off and not having
sex yeah ah
you know
they're just jacking off my ideas
they're not having sex that makes sense
because as uh as women
scientifically we
release more
i forgot i think ever at the what we
release when we have sex that makes us
want that intimacy
with whoever we're having sex with we
there are some women who can just be
like i'm just have sex with him and not
care but there's something like in the
back of your mind that you still care
about that person because if you saw if
you had sex with that dude one day the
next day he goes and has sex with
another female you're going to feel some
type of way because of what we release
when we have sexual interaction with
them and it's just something that
we cannot
bypass because it's in us so
it's
it's hard to
be able to um
to
sleep around and i mean i'm speaking for
me it's hard to be able to sleep around
with multiple people and not have that
like oh i wonder if he's like thinking
about me or whatever
like because it's just like it's just
what
what like we release when we do interact
with them like that yeah and men can
have sex with like
like i always i've said this so many
times on the show but it's like the day
you realize you have to worry about the
ugly girls too
because like men can have
like men can have sex with literally
anyone anyone anyone
and be okay yeah like so as i said men
can have sex with a woman today and
another woman tomorrow and at three
women today and
be okay and it's not like oh like you
just said it's like he's not thinking oh
i wonder if they're thinking about me
just like no i just yeah
i just done that
it's totally different imagine if a guy
gives you the best sex to your life like
mine
she says
been there done that
lucky girl but then he then he never
talks to you again
after seven years and still texts me
imagine
no but she's saying imagine if a guy did
yeah and i'm saying like he did not
yeah he did sorry
go on pal sorry you get your point now
i'm saying women have a harder time with
that and then it sort of ruins you a
little bit for your husband because now
you compare to him like your future
husband to that guy
and that's not really it's not really
fair like guys guys aren't really like
that they they have sex they're good but
like girls will compare
the next guy to the last guy so then
these guys feel like they have to like
be these
corn stars
to like please a girl you know what i
mean and like they feel like they have
these unrealistic standards and then and
then longer way to please a girl than uh
i know he's a man right so it's harder
and yeah yeah it is and most of men they
don't do the work
they just what's that well the work is
is being a hoe basically that's how they
get and that is why and then women don't
then women feminists say oh they can't
be hoes either the guys
but then that's why but that's why paul
that's why the women that get that good
sex keep calling that guy for that good
sex
right and so we we've spoke we they do
they
[Music]
remember when you said the majority the
men who give good sex let's just say men
that give good sex
they have
the women that they've given good sex to
right all of those women want that guy
to give them good sex again so the guys
that are giving good sex to women
are are heavily sought after by these
women
right
and so and so
the other
he's he he understands okay cool like i
have sex blah blah i mean he may be a
hole in the streets or whatever but he
knows that those women will con
consistently be coming back
for him
that he knows that there's because he's
given that he's given them that release
that jess was talking about right and
those women want that release and so
when they're comparing other guys
they're like those guys are just a bit
let me call this guy and he's like oh
okay you're calling now all right cool
so i had a call from susan on the monday
and then i don't know francesco on a
tuesday and he's just like okay cool
here's my options and that's why they
say men are dogs that's why a lot of the
things this whole men are dogs thing is
because those men are having sex with
these women well and it's interesting if
you ask 80 of women what they want in a
guy they list 20 of men right so the
reason we hate men and they say things
like men are trapped like if a girl says
men are trash it basically says she's
for the streets because it's the men
you're picking
and you're picking the guys that are
sleeping with everybody
yeah women aren't going for average
dudes no
like this degree
all right i love medium ugly men i think
they're great okay i love average men i
think they're better looking than good
looking ones
you know but usually when girls say that
the guys that they they think are medium
ugly are still above average
she's like yeah he's like no i had sex
with a hunchback
i've never had sex in public so
definitely not under a bridge
it's all right you're young you've got
time
[ __ ]
anyway let's move on uh